j'ai besoin d'une photo en couleurs de
george washington c'est suis à la
recherche d'un globe terrestre vous en
avez à taille réelle je suis à la
recherche d'une liste de loi que je
puisse enfreindre pour qu'on me renvoie
disant
quelques mois en prison
bonjour nique bonjour monsieur goodson
c'est vraiment génial d'avoir une
activité on passe ses journées à lire
il ya que des poivrots est dingue
monsieur vous allez devoir remettre vos
vêtements tu vas t'en occuper parce que
là c'est un massacre intel qui lâche
anthony du
le corps d'un sans abri a été retrouvé
devant l'entrée de la bibliothèque avec
un froid comme ça je sais pas pourquoi
on nous permet pas de rester ce goodson
faut qu'on discute on manque d'abris
pour nous qui vivent dans la rue c'est
qu'ils nous
on pourrait tous venir dans votre appart
ya plein de voitures de flics est-ce que
tout va bien les usagers organise une
action la bibliothèque n'a pas été
déclarée centre d'accueil d'urgence à
gré
donc là c'est peut-être pas le meilleur
moment pour me faire faire ma carte de
bibliothèque sans commande
[Musique]
je suis l'inspecteur bill rams tête de
retard vous devrez ouvrir cette porte va
être contrainte à les faire sortir
je ne suis pas préparé à une
confrontation avec la police et pas toi
qui dis toujours vive la résistance
là ça va plus loin que prendre le métro
et acheter la nourriture biologique
[Musique]
on est une bibliothèque pas un refuge
pour sans abri pourquoi tout ça dans
quel but
pour leur dire qu'il faut compter avec
non
utilisez les pour de la nourriture ou un
hôtel vous allez me donner de l'argent
et dire qu'en faire vous connaissez mes
besoins
déduit que c'est une manifestation sans
vérité pourquoi vous ne passez pas le
type qui vous dicte votre texte non je
parle pas avec la police
[Rires]